let's talk about setting yourself up for
wealth as far as what you need to
understand with that
and on top
actually i'm going to tie in another
point with that with debt so let's talk
about debt first
you need to completely avoid debt
the amount of
people that acquire unsecured debt
and let it pile up and pay absurd
interest rates
is just it's just bonkers and i i still
have an interest in my debt relief
company like i i spent almost 20 years
building that thing up um and prior to
that you know i worked in credit
collection so i understand that that
that part of the financial world the
financial instruments that are available
very very well
debt is dumb i can't i can't say it you
know loud and clear enough i mean i
structure the business in such a way
that it helps people get edited quickly
and resolves problems on their credit
bureau but
that business would not exist if people
didn't make bad choices with money um
starting in your 20 and i'll be honest
with you guys one of the strategies that
we've seen um credit issuers make
is they'll is they'll try to hit young
people in college university um they
have booths they offer student credit
cards or unsecured lines of credit and
the like and um
the strat and the thinking behind it is
i mean if you're 20
they'd rather give a unsecured credit
card to a 20 year old with a 20 000
limit than an unsecured credit card to a
55 year old
with the same limit because a 20 year
old is going to live longer and they're
going to be on the hook for more
interest payments are going to be on the
hook for more money owed interest
penalties they're very very clever okay
when it comes to structuring financial
instruments and convincing you to to
take advantage of them
i'm not going to use the exact language
uh that i've heard some credit card
issuers and banks use but sound bites
along the lines of you got way more
money than you think or you could be
more wealthier than where you think you
are right now sort of thing
um
and they target young people at college
and you you know and these universities
because they want you to sign up take it
don't worry about it just make your
minimum payments everything be fine by
the time you're 30
you're still broke as [ __ ] you've got
loads of debt only now the balance is a
lot higher because the interest and
you're not and you never bring it down
it's never designed
when it says make a minimum monthly
payment it's not designed to pay down
the principal
it actually states on the back of credit
card statements because nobody reads
these [ __ ] things except for me it
actually states in the order that they
apply money
to your to to your debt and it goes to
interest late fees penalties and there's
one or two other that's not principle
and then it goes to principal
okay so
don't think for a minute that they've
got your interest about but your your
best interest at heart and just sign
here and take the card and go and use it
everything will be tickety-boo it
doesn't work that way they want to get
you in a position where
they got you under their thumb
and at some point in the future if you
can wiggle out from under that unsecured
debt that you've accumulated then they
either sell you a mortgage or a car loan
or a retirement savings investment loan
or something along those lines some some
instrument where they don't actually
have the money in the bank like a bank
vault they just type numbers into a
computer screen and it makes more debt
for you because that's how the banking
industry works you want to learn more
about that go watch george gammon
channel
so do not
acquire debt for any reason unless i'll
say this unless it's debt that is going
to help you build wealth
maybe if you're into
renault flips and buying distressed
homes
cleaning them out little lipstick and
makeup on it flip it make some money
you're gonna need a uh a loan for
something like that but you generally
don't need loans to start businesses or
anything else so there are rare
scenarios where it would be beneficial
but generally stay the hell away from it
trust me on that hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you